South Asian influence is embedded in
British culture
contributing to our multicultural
society as a result of the colonial
empire they don't come under
conservatives if it was the
Conservatives anything to do with it
they'll be here but their votes as a
block are no longer guaranteed if you
work it on sort of racism I don't think
they vote for any other now traditional
community habits aren't the main
priority British agents who hold the
balance of power instead it's combined
with what really matters to them
it was the cotton mills of pendel in
Lancashire that brought many Pakistanis
and other Asians to the northwest
generations later the mills are slowly
disappearing but those families remain
one in five people here come from a
South Asian background almost three
times the national average the majority
of them Muslims for years they voted as
a group for labour but modern politics
and the fallout from the EU referendum
are dividing these communities and their
families this constituency has the
second smallest conservative majority in
the northwest
it also has by far the largest ethnic
minority population of any seat held by
the Tories outside of London breakfast
Misbah is Lancashire born and bred she
describes herself as Labour through and
through mainly because of the influence
of her family and the community
everybody but all your friends your
family everybody votes Labour and that's
what it always has been and you know
families a very very loyal we're back
you know they do stick to the fact that
you know no we've always been Labour and
that's why we're sticking to because you
know the Conservatives have always had
what sort of like a reputation of
conservatives a black making the rich
richer and the poor poorer yeah yeah but
to be honest I think is changing now
this concept in the labor I think we're
at that stage now where people do
actually read about the policies they do
actually so it's like the family
politics going out now slowly
but their political views were divided
by the EU referendum miss buzz husband
has named voted to leave what she
supports it remaining at the time they
were misled they weren't given the right
information and I feel the same way I
mean if you ask me now would that war
leave again would I act no I wouldn't
how did you feel knowing that he was
gonna vote leave I'd like to think it
was because we were well informed about
what actually leave and remain meant and
I do think that people a lot of people
would be walked in differently in
December so it's a bit of a godsend this
election in December to be honest with
you miss basri examining her political
opinions every day do you think the
Conservatives could ever win you round
with anything the tried believe me
they've tried you know I've had Asian
uncle's we refer to you know Asian men
in the community that have worked with
my dad you know forty years ago knocking
on my door saying hey you're voting
conservatives this year and I'm not I'm
a you are I used to work with your dad
40 years ago you're gonna vote for me
because I'm Sonny no but I'm thinking
uncle you sort of fully about three or
four years ago I'm sure you did you know
these are the people that came to
England under the layer of government
they didn't come under conservatives if
conservatives anything to do with it
they won't be here for her friends a
group of Pakistani mothers politics
dominates the conversation the elders in
the community else in the family or the
men in the family they like to dictate
what they want the women to do and a lot
of them before I fall into that trap
where well my husband said and I have to
do it I think what we are today is
because of labor our foundation and
anything anything you look at around the
world and it's all was based on the
foundation my daughter said to me she's
a you know she was look he can't sworn
labor all the time you want to look what
they're doing for us what they're not
doing for us as a community why are you
putting in the point why are you taking
out of the pot so would you ever vote
for anyone but labour I would I
personally wouldn't be my household I
know when I wanted four consider two
sons a big Hoover we're all watching
Philippa because everyone like Shabana
said they're too
everybody believes that we labor is the
only party that was supports porters was
Asian South Asians are three point one
bigger voice of the community it's clear
that South Asians in pendel all have
close ties people here are keen to
publicly proclaim their allegiances as
we're from Sky News today to come and
speak to the people of pendel the Asian
and the Muslim voters of pendel to find
out exactly how people are going to vote
in the 2019 general election with an
adult I'll be voting labour I don't see
how any person let alone Asian can vote
Tory you know given that record is there
a way that they could ever win you round
could have any other part or maybe win
around and nothing for labour not a
chance not a chance at all you know I've
abstained from voting in the past I will
walk this time and that's purely because
of Jeremy Corbyn so I'm not quite sure
exactly but I know kind of who I won't
be voting for okay with so much public
support for the Labour Party this
constituency still voted for a
Conservative MP in 2017 Muhammad Tariq
is an estate agent he's been a labor
member his whole life until now and he
believes he's not the only one here to
change sides they have switched a big
way we have a local election last year
and a Tory Party as one very vast
majority in a scene modes if panic as me
can change my views very strong views
and all my I campaign every year if I
can change my views normal people will
change just like that
Maria sobolevskaya
is an expert in voting behavior at the
University of Manchester and studies
voting patterns her research shows that
the community elders grip on a
in voting habits is losing its force
they are behaving more and more like a
white British voter in a sense that they
shop around for a political party
however we also know from research that
Asian and generally ethnic minority
people do couldn't retain these partisan
identities longer and more than the
equivalent young people of white British
origin and we think that is because the
patterns of passing on that identity
from parent to child a stronger in
minority communities since its creation
West Bromwich East has been red another
place where more than one in five people
are Asian who strongly supported the
former deputy leader of the Labour Party
Tom Watson but 68 percent of the
constituency voted to leave the EU and
the blue vote is gaining ground so we've
just made it to West Brom and there's a
trend here similar to the rest of the
country one minority group has
noticeably increase in support for the
Conservative Party both in 2017 and 2015
British Indians in particular Hindus and
Sikhs
for many of them this general election
is about delivering the results of the
EU referendum even if that means
changing lifelong voting habits
this successful metal works in West
Bromwich has a diverse workforce mainly
made up of Indians
Manjeet and Ravi full run the family
business which has been here for decades
you voted labour your whole life why is
that been and why have you changed now
to the Conservatives well because I
voted out now and I know conservative
want to leave now so now I have to
support my vote and I'm happy to vote
Conservatives because to be honest I'm
with Boris now I just want to leave and
I want to be able to set our own rules
and regulations for this country for
businesses for the economy as first
generation Asians being born in this
country typically our parents have just
said to us vote Labour vote Labour
holiday but that's what we've been
bought and brought up with voting labour
as we sort of go into the positions that
we have got to understand what politics
is about we started making our own
decisions so even for you Ravi
someone who's voted labour your whole
life you voted to remain in the EU I did
yes but this time around you're gonna
vote conservatives as well yes I've body
conservatives office I vote
conservatives last two elections because
having inherited the business taking it
over my priorities changed slightly in
terms of what we need from wife myself
my family I think the younger generation
are a lot more educated there's not a
lot of Asians now who are in these sort
of labor intensive jobs I think the
younger generation and us who are sort
of degree based educated going forward
we'll see that conservative as a bit
as Asians we're stuck between a rock and
a hard place with the two main decisions
we've got to make conservative labor
because they're the only two parties
that can really get anything done
you've got the anti-semitism right with
labor you've got the letterbox RA with
Boris Johnson again the certain things
you've got to see through and we've got
to make it policy based if you work it
on sort of racism I don't think we'd
vote for any of them
Manjeet sweetly Bhangra class is an
opportunity to reconnect with the
culture of a parents generation even if
her political views have evolved at this
class music and dance may bring these
women together but the division in this
community is apparent
I don't like Jeremy Corbyn and it's not
personal he's doing and I just think if
we tried to change now we tried to go to
the labor we'll just put ourselves back
five years again because but all we're
trying to do is conservatives have been
there so long now and we need to get our
priority at the moment it's just to get
breaks it done yeah bits so long but in
that space of time in that state of
abeyance what's happened it doesn't
matter what will happen is the same with
means if you read them the conservative
manifesto it's actually trying to undo
everything it has done while it's been
in power it took away nurses now wants
to put it back they took away teachers
they took away the face now they want to
put them back and why do you take the
win ladies it's hard to ignore the
sounds of British Asians keen to share
their political views professors so
burlaps cos research shows that South
Asian votes are up for grabs and the
main parties can win or lose this key
demographic I think this is an
interesting election a lot of Asian
origin and generally a minority origin
voters do vote along very similar lines
to the white British voters so they will
want to vote on economic competence on
the NHS on education on issues like that
I think in a handful of marginal
constituencies the British agents could
hold the balance of power if it proves
that the Conservative Party can
successfully appeal to them
and while the Conservative Party has
been trying to win over this demographic
for decades the leave campaign achieved
that in a matter of months
at this general election the increasing
number of South Asians in the UK could
hold the balance of power